Okay,
now you know what you see on the left
there at the top on the.
Sorry,
on the right at the top you see a
picture of an old man kissing Joseph
Stalin,
which is quite a weird thing to do.
Given that Joseph Stalin was probably
responsible for the deaths of some
number of people in excess of 10
million,
perhaps an excessive 30 million people
argue about this all the time.
He certainly starved 6 million
Ukrainians to death in the 19 thirties,
which is something that you know,
for some reason you don't hear much
about your education,
but you know,
6 million Ukrainians probably worth
noticing a little bit,
but it doesn't matter because this old
man,
this was taken after the fall of the
Berlin Wall.
He's nostalgic for the times when
everything was certain you know,
and the,
the Gold Statue of style and his
representation in some sense of a day of
five leader.
And the old man is there is in a
position of worship and then captain
hook there at the bottom on the right
hand side.
He is quite an interesting character
because he's basically a tyrant.
And the Peter Pan Story is very
interesting because Peter Pan Pan Sorta
means everything and Peter Pan is the
sort of person who wants to retain the
dynamic potential of childhood because
when you're a child you're not anything
but you could be anything.
So you're pretty much only potential.
And then you might say,
well why should you sacrifice that
potential to become something actual?
Because in some sense it's actually a
limiting process.
So for example,
and I mean this in the most concrete
possible way,
you have more neural connections when
you're born than you do at any other
time in your life.
And most of those die by the time you're
too.
So you go through this tremendous
pruning process from when you're born,
from when,
til two.
So it's like you're dying into your
childhood personality.
And then again,
the same thing happens at the end of
adolescence between say 16 and 21,
which is also the peak time for risk for
the emergence of schizophrenia.
And some people think that's the pruning
process gone wrong.
But you know,
as an adolescent you also shed childhood
potential to become the limited.
But specialized and potentially useful
thing that you will become.
And so you might say,
well,
is it worth it?
Is it worth shedding that potential?
And Peter Pan's answer to that is,
well no,
he wants to remain in Neverland as a
magical boy forever and he's King of the
lost boys,
which I would say is not a very.
That's not much of a dominance
hierarchy,
right?
It's like you're,
you're the king king of the King of the
losers,
so to speak.
People who can't get their act together
and mature now.
And you notice in Peter Pan,
peter pan doesn't grow up.
He doesn't establish a relationship with
Wendy who's actually real.
He has to settle for Tinkerbell who is a
ferry and they don't exist.
And so she's really in some sense of
figure of his imagination because he
won't mature.
He have an actual relationship with,
with a genuine person.
So he has to satisfy himself with while
it's something like a pornographic
fantasy actually.
So seriously it is.
It is like that.
I mean,
it's,
it's toned down a lot in the movie
version obviously,
but still,
that's what's underlying it.
Now you might say,
well why doesn't Peter Pan want to grow
up?
And the answer is the only figure of
authority that's around for him.
His P,
his captain hook,
and he doesn't like Captain Hook.
And that's because captain hook is a
tyrant.
He's brutal,
you know,
and he's also a coward because he's,
he's lost a hand already to a crocodile
with a clock in its stomach.
That's chaos and time,
you know,
that's the dragon that lives underneath
everything.
It's like the basset lists can Harry
Potter and that Damn Crocodile's already
got it.
Piece of him,
which is exactly the case.
That crocodile has got a piece of me,
you know,
I'm older than 50 and so time is already
got its grip on me.
And you know,
part of the problem of being adult is
that you also have to take the fact that
your finite and limited into account.
And if you're terrified by that,
which people tend to be,
then it can easily turn you into a
tyrant because you're afraid of
everything or disgusted by everything
and you have to ramp up the amount you
control it.
And so Peter Pan looks at Captain Hook
and he thinks there's no damn way.
That's what I want to end up as.
So he's got a bad role model,
you know.
So Captain Hook and Stalin and this sort
of devouring monster are good
representations of the negative or
tyrannical element of the great father.
So that's the tyrannical element of the
dominance hierarchy.